We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p.
We did reach 700,000 youtube subscribers yesterday.
And uh, today's voicemail is about that.
Hey David Renin here.
Uh, congratulations on getting to 700,000
subscribers.
Thank you.
Curious that draw the goal is 1 million.
Um, what are you going to do to entice more
subscribers?
You're going to do, uh, the more shows that
you know product in your hair, you're going
to do a Janga Games.
Um, I don't know.
Those are fun.
Yeah, listen, I mean, my thought is I don't
know that we should be drastically changing
what we're doing in order to get to a million
subscribers.
That's an amazing goal.
Based on the recent subscriber trends, we
are sort of on target to hit a million youtube
subscribers in June of 2020 in, in great time
for the 2020 election.
It would be amazing to be covering the 2020
election as a youtube channel with over a
million subscribers.
But to be honest, the, the growth curve has
been accelerating.
It only took us four months to get four months
to get our last 100,000 subscribers.
It took seven months to get the prior 100,000.
So it's accelerating and I don't know that
I'm inclined to change a much of anything.
We're going to just keep doing our thing.
And part of that is doing not only a really
good broadcast show every day, but a really
good bonus show every day.
On today's, we will talk about Donald Trump's
latest unhinged Afghanistan comments, as well
as two men who have been bizarrely
fined for eating raw squirrels to protest
of veganism.
Very, very strange way to protest all of those
stories and more on today's bones, the David
Pakman show@da